easy actionable things that people can  do to reduce stress levels are you  getting enough sleep is probably the  single most important foundation to  being able to recoup your resilience  during the day what I find with stress  people start to breathe in a shallow  manner or they hold their breath so a  lot of people when they're scrolling on  social media are actually holding their  breath and they don't really realize  that so just remembering to breathe  deeply each hour when you check in on  okay how am I feeling emotionally also  just check in on like How Deeply you're  breathing and maybe just do 10 deep  breaths for the sake of it anyway